marcus fenix ago I cool hey everybody
welcome to another gamespot plays Don
you are here with Marrakech we're gonna
play some gears of war Ultimate Edition
which came as nine years ago oh sorry
yes this one's coming in the not so
distant future the original gears of war
came out back in 2006 and now I feel
very old it well especially if you go
back and look at the old graphics yeah
this looks great it does this looks this
marcus fenix looks super HD look at show
me Dom it's dom black HD look at that my
best friend see this is how I remember
the game looking but I'm sure if we did
a side-by-side years Jack had Barry his
hair did not look that nice and tough
day came out of a final fantasy we're at
we're playing the single-player this is
my fault like the second chapter you
want me to play the first and let's live
right on into it this is running at 30
frames per second in 1080 you are full
of grenades already with which to tag
people and you've already played the
first part of the game the first chapter
did this feel like Gears of War did you
like get back in the swing of real
quickly oh I think so I mean it feels
the same even even maybe the things that
you might not love about it or similar
like me of some of the AI is a little
funky but you you get that same vibe of
just the love and nostalgia of it I love
the you know
sure God boomers in the face then we're
gonna really yeah yeah what takes the
takes a little bit of time I [ __ ] up
my real one this is one of its all
coming back this is one of the most
difficult games to talk and play as well
and from well I won't win this game came
out I was a I'm coming up on ten years
as a gamespot user at registered so this
this was like hot in that era and often
it was people playing this video game
and that the two sequels afterwards in
the prequel and getting their asses
handed to it so if you miss a couple of
active reloads don't worry about it too
much just makes you feel like a jerk try
doing that trying to win them yeah
nailed it got the boost and everything I
wonder it's like a little bit of it as
reflex memory because you you remember
the timing of it oh no beard burns down
oh and another thing you must remember
about the gears of war games is people
getting down and you often to run over
and save their asses snipey and then
vice versa yeah I got good have you what
bodies have you come up against oh we I
had my first boomer standard locus
toward and uh come after me any clicky
click ease yes a few but not the ones
that I have the yellow goo attached oh
yeah thats gears of war two is it is
they come up here too really lambent oh
that's later on so this is the evening
this is like a night fall campaign so
later on you get some lamb vents and
they're yellow and they explode that
kind of sets up later on when you find
out that the lambeth oh here we go Gears
of War spoilers 10 years in the making
yeah that the lamb bed eventually there
you go come on
do it uh the yeah the lambent actually
end up going against the locust and
that's a whole new story but that's like
effing tired I have like no concept for
what happens where like is it was it was
it which game was Dom's wife whole thing
in hey that was a second one second one
okay I like it when I go down there and
they find out that there's yet tag doc
jerk that's my plate this is gamescom
the exact same thing today those [ __ ]
the minute I go hey Stacey yeah maybe
they know that they're doomed I wonder
how much they know I gotta go back a
little bit no worries uh yeah so how're
you finding it how you enjoying it
enjoying it ya know it's it's got the
same feel i love it i love this game
when i played it before this was
probably been one of the very first
shooters i ever played hmm oh wow boomer
oh yeah boomer this is one of the very
first games I ever played and it really
it gives you that feeling right back
it's like the camaraderie of your
friends but it's a nice shooter that you
it has some difficulty to it obviously
but it's not too difficult you could
definitely oh man you killed me again
yeah uh it's more difficult when you're
talking about the game just forgiving as
well I think I always felt me
yeah it was one of the it was like not
many shooters of this ilk especially on
console like people don't tend to play
them in hard mode but there's something
about gears where people were sort of
more willing to give this game a shout
on like hardcore like because it was
easy but challenging sort of a normal
mode and then when you played it a bunch
more thank you oh Jesus feel that it was
gonna hit me yeah but yeah people were
kind of like willing to give it a go in
hardcore mode because it's it's it's one
of those games where you need I it's
like super fair like you get you get
what you died and you figure it out and
you get better at the game because
you're like okay no you know what oh
jesus that was good I can tell you a lot
to like how many times he playing it
there like why don't you try flanking
what you're actually supposed to do uh
so it shouldn't shouldn't be too hard
but you know they find a way still with
the amount of bad guys that they throw
at you for you to die and decent at all
and you are big into your co-op games
did you play here's one and co-op always
oh yeah okay it really enjoyed playing
this in what screen there was something
really enjoyable about it to me like to
communicate with someone in person and
side by side scream at them it's raised
easier when they're right there beside
you not just on the internet yeah and
then you jump right into multiplayer
right after that mmm screwing with
people on the internet in 60 frames per
second now so many friends yeah in 1080
and again like if you if you forget if
you wonder like oh it doesn't look that
good go back and look at the original
one you are wrong well the one amazing
one of my favorite things as well as
what is like gears came out like two
thousand six which like people forget
like the YouTube is not YouTube we now
know and love back in two thousand six
so even if you go to like look up
youtube footage of gears like capturing
cabins were so bad that it just looks
like [ __ ] vaseline mulch it's just
powerful it looks like nothing even like
the original so if you go back and watch
video of it it's like oh god like this
looks like a goddamn PlayStation 2 game
when is the fact that was like for the
time it was like a super technically
impressive game and I'm one of the
biggest games in terms of like it's
online connectability oh yeah I'm the
xbox 360 this is one of the first games
I remember seeing furniture and when
it's shot it actually exploded that oh
my god how do you do that like now it's
not that exciting but at the time color
me impressed and it's cool oh look its
gears of war one everyone's being an
idiot yeah I don't know how much effort
they went into the AI but it's as you
would have expected them it's like
nostalgia wrinkles and all just take it
as it is it's not Oh what the [ __ ] yeah
just hang a net though you're like don't
worry about us we're just don't we're
peaceful yeah there was an earlier one
where I saw bears like chainsawing one
of them and he just glitched out jumped
all around and then bear just chainsaw
to nothing for a good solid like few
minutes it was weird yeah but you know I
forgave it back in the day to I mean
they used to always get in my way when
you're setting up and you're trying to
if you have a better spot to try to
[ __ ]
yeah well like back in 06 as well like
we were still really like escort
missions back then or you know or even
like AI buddies like what was a
half-life 2 came in 2004 and they had
all the Alyx Vance oh I guess no it was
episode to episode one where they had it
was actually warmer they had all the
Alex Van Slyke bloody missions and I was
like the first time you had like a co-op
buddy who wasn't a total [ __ ] garbage
and kept getting you killed you know
yeah and gears was kind of on the crest
of that wave as well so yeah there's
probably lot of stuff that we forgave
back then that might seem a little bit
rougher and yeah just today gray and you
and you kind of got to give it that a
little bit um just a little break here
and junk give me you yeah it's it's
risky given away we shot gonna look how
kind funny you that's some gears of war
[ __ ] right there on the ground in front
you look want your toes just just have
enough liquor little bit uh yeah ah yes
so gross mostly yeah I hope we come
across the couch it's always fun to like
break those up it doesn't make any sense
why that would give you any joy but at
the time oh my lord are the stranded wow
this is this is weird cuz I've I haven't
played this game in like six years and
it's like a you're saying before going
live it's like this strange kind of like
dream version of a real like I kind of
remember this [ __ ] but yeah it feels
like a dream you remember when you hit
why that it told you what to do and it
would say this is a possible car oh yeah
never that oh gosh cuz these are the
kinds this was the game that like back
in the day actually I don't know how to
push this dogs net boom shot thought
maybe it's cuz you've got the thing in
your hand oh it's got a dip on it I
totally forgot about that I forget a
mini of things oh that was a shot I
think I got it Dom can wait for that
shot oh my god uh but yeah you remember
doing that stuff because a lot of a lot
of gears wasn't so much about oh oh okay
a lot of gears wasn't about shooting it
perfectly it was about getting in the
right position which is why they used to
always say stuff like Blanco them and
stuff you
wasn't it wasn't always about just being
a perfect shot it was about it was about
knowing the right thing to do in any
given scenario yeah that's true he
always stayed true to that hot coals
dead hahaha call James a you he'll be
fine you live too obviously I'm off his
name of the american football US post
name is sport again oh but not funder
ball but uh Lightning Bowl night they're
all [ __ ] dead you're like this is
like what this is what it's like playing
online the first week there's one behind
you as well it's that guy is gonna kill
me if I leave all right I'm going get up
you don't really stop go behind you go
is if I friendly yeah if I if I die or
if they live it's fine yeah now I have
to redo it again you explode you just
shot you and you just exploded the like
three or four parts doms noises when he
like fine things that he likes like
sweet nice and he like says really weird
[ __ ] cuz that was that was his thing on
yeah sure not how many times have you
raised your finger to your ear and
walked slowly in this game yeah I like
to I like to hear just the weird things
that you had
I remember all of their really it's so
impressive so I want their dialogue
looks really good in memorable and this
is available depending on where the
world you live it's like 40 bucks just
on like that I take over here and but
also if you buy this game before I
believe December 31st of this year you
also guess all of the old gears games
literally like one two three four and
judgments yeah Amy [ __ ] woods yeah ask
about it oh yeah so whenever that
preview program is goes like fully like
out there for everyone I guess this is
the only one that looks that's nice yeah
this is this is the only HD so you'll
get older like the original look nice
good zoom yeah so the people are home to
enjoy that really nice yeah you'll get
all those games again so any get to
relive the whole story the whole story
that bit with the zombie lady and then
oh who could forget the bit with the
inside them that was in this one where
you go inside the beast inside the worm
yeah that was at this one I was alright
that was the big actually never I think
about it this one also has the pc only
missions like there's an entire hidden
chapter I think it's chapter 5 it's
before the ram train stuff and after
Marcus's family homestead stuff there's
like this whole extra bottle and a bunch
of med levels that they own your water
you get some bonus and then
so that's amazing another good reason to
have it it's a pretty you know as you
know as cash grabs go this is a pretty
good vehicle cash grab yeah a lot of
bang for your buck in this one and I
don't want to know nobody wants to
hammer first it'll mean the history
gears of war that's a real oh [ __ ] I ran
out of ammunition or I accidentally
picked this up when I was doing
something do you remember like the old
way used to do this is with the d-pad
and yeah you have to choose the right
gun that you want to switch out with the
one you want yeah and I always remember
like pitching out with a gun I actually
wanted you don't realize for like five
minutes you know when you've just the
autoloaders already happened yeah and
you have a hammer of dawn and you're
indoors this is worthless alright I
think you got one more bottle in you and
haha yes hit wide to look at things
stranded gatekeeper that's it that's one
of the dudes that's one of the like
friendly guys he's gonna be like hey
what's going on yeah you saw you stuck
in zoom mode you're out of it no I just
wanted to look at him hey buddy so
what's up same old [ __ ] there you go
Gears of all Ultimate Edition same old
[ __ ] this guy said this kind of looks
like fallout to me this like shot where
this guy is talking yeah I could
definitely see that you get in or is he
just being weird find Franklin leader of
the local stranded okay just let these
like for birdie dudes with chainsaw guns
just wander in oh don't like us they
don't want to touch me so there's
different factions and depending on what
you are in is whether or not people like
you oh yeah cuz you're like you're part
of the COG man yes turn your low get low
mom brasher ball crusher is that it yeah
didn't just come to you yeah it did it
wasn't like written on that guy's dirty
or anything I thought about it for a
really long time roscher bowl you can
see the lightning and everything's
definitely like way improved since the
2006 game this kind of looks all right
right and this is supposed to be future
America where we eat wrap hey man this
isn't earth this is Sarah that's a giant
hammer Lady Sarah little cold yeah well
they eat rots and Sarah as well and
they've also got Chinese lanterns which
is great yeah looks nice oh we're gonna
see a cutscene these look very good
these are all completely you know
remastered and they look beautiful I
think they like re did like mocap and
everything for this stuff I think they
have they completely redid everything up
scratch and you can really see it don't
worry i will let you down don't let me
down Dom hey Santiago what you doing
here I dare you used to play let's more
people so sorry fresh of all right now
he didn't play basketball he did not
damn it I was Coltrane he's married for
now she's a real looker yeah I'm not
giving you my ride yo oh I want to
remember this this is one of the worst
see this is where I think you have to
drive the whole again um god this is a
trip damn everything all right all right
this is fun I'm looking forward to
playing this for the like the main fact
that like I'm just going to be guessing
what happens next it'll be like watching
friends again for the flick first time
like 10 years you're like oh this is the
one where the witch is turkey on your
head on with the lamb yeah here it is yo
yeah this is the one where I think
sailed with bats and they come and get
you unless you hit them with light
really hard it's not an easy area it's
not it's not easy and it's also kind of
tedious yes one of the worst
combinations of video games what will
forgive us his gears of war is kind of
all right I'm there is the another
trophy the gears franchise which is two
of them wandering off and the other two
doing their own lit up you know left you
go right none of us wear helmets let's
all wear really big gear that's like I
always wanna hang out with Dom look it's
never Baird where it's like always
Marcus not go away Dom you come with me
you [ __ ] do your own thing you can
deal with it all right let's let's wrap
it up there and marrakech gears of war
ultimate edition review coming on the
site in the next little while yeah take
a trip down memory lane I think it's
absolutely such an enjoyable thing to
remember and all those memories just
come rushing back all those beautiful
memories forty dollars for nostalgia
pangs get it on xbox one real soon let
us know what you think I vacuumed Oh
ultimate edition in the comment box
below and we'll see you next time on
gamespot plates my nice nice no better
anja noise yo it's all [ __ ]